so we're here yeah and um lovely you've
made some kind of a drink this is a
cocktail i'm calling the chilled chum
like shark chum
it's a bourbon oh wow pomegranate juice
lemon juice and muddled strawberries
that's the chum yeah and that's us we're
the chill chums look at i mean is this
not living this is how podcasting should
be done you're out on a fire no you're
not on fire no no no fortunately the
fire is contained because of the good
people at solar stove i didn't drive
here i'm gonna get [ __ ] up
is that true you didn't drive i didn't
drive did you get here uh tac dro
dropped me off we have one car now so he
we share a car and he dropped me off so
i you know i'm gonna have to figure out
how to get him hey maybe i'll give you a
ride home no you won't i would no
because then you're going to do a whole
thing about it i'm going further i how
many favors am i going to do for you
this week
how many favors have i done you've done
a lot this week especially do you want
to tell people on this while we're
sitting around this nice campfire and
having this lovely cocktail that gourley
made what the favor was that uh my wife
and i did for you on sunday onsen you
you and liza were uh i asked you guys to
be my kids godparents and you but is
that a favor no no it's not that's a
disservice
[Laughter]
i really didn't i kept channeling
michael corleone
because they did have a part where they
were saying do you renounce evil yeah
yeah
and i kept thinking i'm evil incarnate
yeah you are i am uh
i'm the solidified gel of evil uh i i i
cannot it was it was it a beautiful you
know give you a little fun fact if
you're trying to picture out there
this uh wonderful christening ceremony
for sona's twins michael and charlie
one of the things that uh
you can know
is that the church was featured at the
end of a very important film do you know
which film it was well what church where
are we talking it's about montebello and
it's an armenian church it's quite
lovely give me a hint it's not a real
old movie i want to say it's about 15
years old yeah fast and the furious
tokyo dress yes very good it was fast
and furious tokyo drift no um it was
sideways and the movie sideways at the
end when thomas hayden church gets
married he gets married uh at the very
end of the movie after all their
misadventures when his nose is all
banged up and his eyes are black and
blue
they show him getting married at this
beautiful armenian church that's the
church yeah and the week before well i'm
gonna go ahead no i would you can say it
because i think you the way you found
out was actually it was really fun
because we get there
and the church is pretty empty i'm there
i'm wearing a suit my wife
as always very beautifully turned out
beautiful
and um
this priest comes out and he gestures to
me to come backstage because as the
godfather
they want me to wear a ceremonial robe
yep
and so it's just it's a real thing so
they bring me back the guy seems kind of
pissed that i'm so tall yeah so he's
like oh and he's going through this
closet of robes so man he was like
suddenly
he was a disgruntled wizard like looking
through robes
and then finally he pulled out a robe
and then he said uh
and he said
you sing your name your name your name
is and i said conan he went yes yes
conan conan was here last week too he
says it in broken english and i said
what
conan gray the pop star was here
and he said no
he said conan here last week and and
other conan and i'm like there's no
other conan trust me i wish there was
but there's no other we all wish there
was a different conan but he said no no
conan conan conan and then he said
matrix
and i said
and he went yeah
and i'm like those are totally different
and but i realized i had to get on his
good side if he's going to give me the
robe
so
i said oh yeah that's a mistake people
make all the time they say hey keanu
reeves oops i'm sorry i meant conan
o'brien because you guys look so yeah
and we're both yeah incredibly handsome
rugged action stars yeah
um
and uh
he said yes and then he found on his
phone that it was in like the montebello
chronicle and it's a picture of keanu
reeves standing like five feet from
where i'm standing with the same priest
was he just was he doing a christening
or were they shooting a movie
i don't know what he was doing i didn't
know we have no idea why hasn't he been
on the podcast i know let's get him on
there what are you talking about we have
we get to talk to everybody keanu will
be here eventually keanu can you come on
our podcast please yeah i bet he listens
yeah well he's clearly i i think he came
by to try and meet me and he got his
dates mixed up
well they say in the spy world the best
way to trail someone is to be ahead of
them so he was there a week ahead yes
yes
desperately wants to bump into me so he
can drop the name of the podcast my
podcast and sort of say like i like
podcast dude and then i can be like i
don't know okay keanu if you think this
is something you want to do but um
anyway so we do we go ahead and we have
the ceremony and it was really beautiful
it was real and you know what they asked
you if you wanted to say the words in
english and you had been practicing in
armenia
well i don't have one of them was huis
yeah there was one that was what's the
really hard one
that's not hard
well
you say it if you've been drinking i was
drinking i've been drinking
and i had taken a lot of pills in the
parking lot
that your
he came up to me yeah is there an update
and he was like going to remember me and
i'm like yes of course i remember you
every night you told me i could lose 10
pounds yeah and we almost got into it in
the parking lot what did he say does he
still feel that way i don't know he kind
of it was a time for him to say you look
good or you know i said that but i gotta
say now that i see you s in daylight
standing up you look good he didn't say
anything oh we got to get him on the
podcast
no we don't no no no it could get bad
really fast well so his english is is
not great any i mean he's been here for
a long time i don't know why it's so bad
but he you know okay he probably called
you keanu
he said i was great in the matrix
he said he loved me
he said he loved me on point break
you're great in the john wick movie uh
so i gotta say my wife killed it mm-hmm
she did a genius thing
to do too well she doesn't have
the the it's a patriarchal system i'm
just gonna call it out it is so it's all
like the male i wear the robe i'm the
one who leads the way i'm the one that's
you know holding children at one point
you know i couldn't hold both of them no
he couldn't they're
just devils oh okay or they're too heavy
well no it's just like holding two you
can't imagine two really powerful
juicing blenders that were turned on
yeah
that are filled with rocks and you're
trying to hold on to them um
just animals more and we put them down
on our living room floor and quickly
learned what we had to child proof yeah
yeah which was both of them
each one has to be each one of her
children needs to be child proof against
the other
so um
my you know what my so the day before
yeah we had we had a bot mitzvah that we
went through the day before and so we
were just killing it this weekend with
lots of things that we went to and
we come back from the bat mitzvah and
i'm exhausted and i was like i'm just
gonna go lie down and my wife said well
i'm gonna run to the toy store and pick
up some little toys that will help
distract sona's kids when they melt down
during the christening
and i was like oh that's not gonna
happen
just taking a nap and i passed out uh
like you know i'd been shot with a blow
dart and
she shows up and she's bought all these
little things and she put them in her
purse and sure enough at the very
beginning of the ceremony i think when
they saw the crucifix yeah these two
start shrieking and
steaming no they don't burning they're
just getting restless and their eyes
were like little red coals oh my god
they were retained
first
nobody my wife liza god bless her she
such a person she takes out two finger
puppets
one is a little silver robot oh my god
and one is a little like a dragon again
and she starts doing this and both of
them are like
and then they're like
oh behold and they take these two finger
puppets and they put them in their
mouths and they were angels the rest of
the time they got dunked in with holding
these finger puppets yeah yeah they they
wouldn't let them go those are vintage
by the way they're made of asbestos oh
good okay
ate it up